well it's important when we think about
population and it is and I am concerned
about it we're talking probably around
three billion people between now and
2050 and I do think it is an issue but I
also want to be careful to say because a
lot of people then take that and use it
as an anti-immigrant or you know could
potentially racist kind of thing when we
look at who is using the most energy and
water in the world it isn't the places
in the world where the population is
exploding it's here in North America
where their worst energy guzzlers and
the worst water guzzlers at followed by
Australia which has no water left and
Europe so it's very important for us I
think to realize that it's the
industrial model and the individual use
overuse and abuse of these resources
that that is the issue when then you
compound that with growing population
which is then growing in areas of the
world that are industrializing so at the
industrializing China the
industrializing India with the class
structure where their upper class is
buying you know all the stuffs and more
that we have here that's the thing
that's unsustainable so it's the
connection between population and
consumerism and industrialization that
we have to put together and if we in the
global North don't want the global South
to destroy all of its water and energy
sources we better we better admit that
our development model may not be the
best one and then but we're going to
have to show some leadership as well and
cutting back because how do you ask
people in a poor country to cut back
when we won't cut back ourselves you
know it's quite a lot to ask really if
you think of it it's like saying well
we'll all cut our emissions or we'll all
cut our water use or whatever by twenty
percent but if you're you know somebody
described it if you're 80 pounds and
you're supposed to just cut your food
consumption by you know twenty percent
you're going to die if you're 200 pounds
probably you can cut your food
consumption by twenty percent and then
some right so similarly I think we could
think of ourselves as being kind of
gluttons in the global north and
maybe we can cut more than our share so
that the global South isn't taking the
entire front